it is a neighborhood still haunted
by the events of three days in august
1971.
ten civilians were killed when members
of the parachute regiment opened fire in
bali murphy
the dead included a catholic priest two
teenagers and a mother of eight children
the last words my mummy said was the
army wouldn't shoot you mommy wouldn't
hurt you so she felt him
safe the victims families say no one
should be above the law she'd bright red
her
she'd coat sandals a dress on
they could see very easily that she was
a woman
and not only that they fired at her
but the first shot was aimed straight at
her face
now to me that's personal
belfast was an uproar the detention of
ira suspects without trial
causing serious unrest the army reported
a gun battle in valley murphy
but none of the victims there was armed
that's where
where mrs colony was going when she was
shot to help this young man crown out
the soldier walked over to him the army
officer and
executed him he had up a hand each year
john's dad was shot 14 times he's still
campaigning for justice
i i thought i was a hardened campaigner
until
the evidence started coming out in court
in detail
uh we'll post more them things like that
they're right
and it was really hard for all of us to
sit
sit through that really hard
five months later the parachute regiment
shot 14 people dead on bloody sunday in
londonderry
the battalion on duty in derry had come
from bali murphy
had these shootings been properly
investigated at the time
bloody sunday may not have happened five
months later
in other words what happened here set in
motion a train of events
that would come to be known as the
northern ireland troubles
the inquest findings are due on the very
day the government's expected to confirm
a halt to historical prosecutions author
brian rowan has written extensively
on how northern ireland might address
its troubled past
i think the only way out of this is an
amnesty that's the only way
to truth or more information it's the
word we will not speak
it's too it's too poisonous but if we
don't go there
then we aren't going to have a legacy
process
or a truth process and with the wars
over we're going to spend the next 30
years
fighting the peace it's not that they
don't want to move on here
it's that their loved ones were never
given that opportunity
david blevins sky news in bali murphy